yes
[Applause]
[Music]
BTS Army and all the suits the suits are
so classic
clean what's the inspiration behind the
looks tonight
um actually Louis Vuitton just made the
suit for only tonight so this is
actually special it's unique custom yeah
yeah
okay only seven describe 2022 in one
word
2022 one word you're welcome
uh nothing beats nothing beats us he
wants salad that's one sentence but
we'll take it but we take it we've got
one more for you tonight's performance
describe it in three words
well we'll better describe in motion
okay you're like okay okay
one two three four
it's like
it goes like this it's like this that's
what that that's what that's what's
gonna happen what what we actually
prepared a new performance yeah never
before seen
we're so I I'm so ready so ready for the
new performance well I'm ready for this
collaboration with Snoop Dogg yes can
you tell us before tell us about that oh
are we going to collaborate with him
come on Snoop call us it's gonna happen
I think didn't he confirm it yes
I don't know actually because you know
the label is going to hate us so so yeah
I don't know I can tell but you all
would love to do a collaboration with
him of course of course
and the Super Bowl was so amazing yeah
do you have a do you have a message you
want to wave to the BTS Army because
they're always watching
j-hope Army stay tuned stay tuned
[Music]